Bisher hielten sich die pläne für die raumstation die um den mond kreisen sollen noch, im wagen aber jetzt scheinen sich die pläne zu konkretisieren
igor komarow chef der russischen raumfahrtbehörde roskosmos
Verkündete jetzt die einigung mit der nasa zum bau der raumstation
Deep space gateway in einer umlaufbahn, um den mond alle infos jetzigen klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Sie wird deutlich kleiner als die ss die
internationale raumstation aber sie hat ein viel größeres ziel ihr name sagt schon aus wohin die reise gehen soll
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes deep space gateway was so viel wie tor in den weltraum
Heißt und es sind ambitionierte
Ehrgeizige pläne für diese station zum ersten mal sollen hier techniken getestet und vorbereitet werden die weltraum missionen in die tiefen des alls
Ermöglichen das erste ziel auf das sich hier vorbereitet wird wäre die mars mission in der umlaufbahn des mondes könnte all das
getestet werden was bei einer mars-mission nötig wäre
nur dass die rückkehr vom mond zur erde in wenigen tagen möglich wäre und sogar mit einem erheblich
Beschädigten raumschiff wie sie apollo 13 mission gezeigt hat damals war zwei tage nach dem start zum mond eine sau ein sauerstofftank
explodiert die mondmissionen musste abgebrochen werden die astronauten
Legten die havarierte kapsel odyssee still und wechselten in die mondlandefähre
Die nicht beschädigt war von dort aus steuerten sie das raumschiff dass sie mit einem swing by manöver
Um den mond wieder auf kurs zu er gebrachten kurz vor erreichen der erde nahmen sie die odyssee
Mit den verbliebenen sauerstoff und energiereserven wieder in betrieb
Koppelten die mondlandefähre ab und landeten mit
Den letzten sauerstoffreserven auf der erde bei einer havarie auf dem weg zum mars wäre das nicht möglich gewesen mit deep space
Gateway wird der mond jetzt zum testgebiet für die nächste generation der raumflüge schon jetzt wird die rakete
für die erste mission gebaut die space launch system
Rakete kurz sls und die orion raumkapsel erste systeme für die mission werden an bord der iss getestet
2024 spätestens
2026 soll es dann losgehen
Die deep space cakes raumstation soll aus drei modulen bestehen dass energie und
antriebsmodul ein wohn modul und ein logistik modul in dem auch experimente durchgeführt werden können bei bedarf sollen weitere
Logistik module angedockt werden hier sollen astronauten aus verlauten dann neue technologien in verschiedenen umlaufbahn
Um den mond testen denn die station ist dazu in der lage in
Unterschiedlichen höhen um den mond zu preisen von gas aus können dann missionen zum mond gestartet werden und so landet technologien und weiteres
Getestet werden der mond wird so zu einem riesigen
Experimentierfeld für lande tests und weitere tests rund um missionen zu fremden planeten
Nach dem durchhänger über den wir erst letztlich hier berichtet haben scheinen jetzt noch endlich erste konkrete schritte zur nächsten
raumstation unternommen zu werden hierzu ist geplant weitere partner wie zum beispiel die europäische weltraumagentur esa mit ins boot zu holen
dafür wird überlegt bestimmte elemente
Jetzt zumindest für die menschheit dem weltraum weit zu normen zitat unser beitrag an der bau von ein bis drei modulen sowie die
entwicklung einheitlicher standards für andock mechanismen für raumschiffe sein zitat ende das meint igor komarow
Die nasa hat sie bis jetzt noch nicht, so konkret geäußert aber es scheint nur noch logisch nach. Dem ende der iss die spätestens
2028 kontrolliert ins meer stürzen muss weil dann niemand mehr für die sicherheit an bord garantieren kann
das ist übrigens auch ein ziel der raumstation
Um den mond die raumstation soll deutlich länger für mehrere jahrzehnte oder vielleicht auch für immer
Im weltraum bleiben zum einen können sie die lebensdauer der module erhöht werden und es könnte ein system der
Erneuerung entwickelt werden durch das alte module regelmäßig durch neue module ausgetauscht werden und auch die kosten werden gegenüber der ist es deutlich
niedriger sein nicht nur die erheblich geringere größe macht die raumstation deutlich preiswerter deep space gateway soll nicht mehr dauerhaft mit
astronauten und astronautinnen gesetzt sein dadurch sind viel weniger
Versorgungsflüge nötig und der energie und sauerstoffverbrauch ist auch viel geringer es geht
Also los mit den missionen in die tiefen
Des alls wenn es neues zu vermelden gibt dann erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier
Wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufs auge unvergesslich den
Genau auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit 1000 raketen zum mars
Da geht es darum wie ihren maske den mars besiedeln will
spannendes video und natürlich also nicht verpassen und draufklicken viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dahin
bleibt dran